[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so last week we had this
hearing where Donald Trump Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh and his first of
many sexual assault accusers Christine
Blasi Ford were questioned by senators
sort of Christine Blasi Ford was
actually questioned by a sexual assault
prosecutor and then was also asked some
questions by Democratic senators
Kavanagh was questioned mostly by
Democratic senators a couple Republican
senators allowed the sex assault
prosecutor to ask him questions and then
with absolutely no explanation
whatsoever after a couple of Republican
senators had delegated their time to the
prosecutor she disappeared and then it
was just glowing remarks and really
tough questions like do you swear to god
you didn't sexually assault a woman were
what we saw from Republican senators
Christine Blasi Ford was calm and direct
and clear Brett Kavanaugh was erratic
unhinged out-of-control yelling ignition
Dignan but also contradictory up
Cavanaugh was boxed into corners
figuratively metaphorically multiple
times about whether he had blacked out
from drinking alcohol but since senators
had only five minutes with him the clock
kept running out as for example senator
Cory Booker made significant headway to
pointing out that the guy's clearly a
liar as senator Blumenthal from
Connecticut made headway and started to
expose Cavanaugh's lies on the matter
and then Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham shows up with the completely
out-of-this-world rant about these
hearings being the most unfair thing
he's ever seen done in politics ever
including to a Supreme Court nominee
which of course borne no connection
whatsoever to the real war
to the facts on the ground but most
importantly Christine Blasi Ford
answered questions and Brett Kavanaugh
avoided answering questions Vox actually
has an interesting graphic which we're
showing our television audience where
they visually show blue for answers and
red for non answers as you can see here
the top graph is Brett Kavanaugh a lot
of red a lot of non answers and then
Christine Blasi Ford answering every
question that was asked for her when it
comes to questions about investigations
Christine Blasi Ford said yes time and
again that she supports an FBI
investigation into her claims Cavanaugh
played coy saying things like I will do
what the committee wants and that an FBI
investigation won't show anything
definitive anyway but still not saying
yeah do an FBI investigation yeah and at
one point dick Durbin asked Kavanaugh
but personally do you want an FBI
investigation
I mean I'd imagine if you're falsely
accused on this this is tough on you and
you want to exonerate yourself yeah and
he just paused for 5-10 seconds he
didn't have an answer to that one and I
think he repeated one of his other
things like the four witnesses in the
room said it didn't happen or one of
these other things that he kept going
back to so let's think for a moment if
Christine Blasi Ford had comported
herself like Brett Kavanaugh did she
would have been called and out of
control not credible hysterical woman on
the basis of her behavior after the
hearings we heard that Republican Jeff
Flake big hero is calling for a delay to
Cavanaugh's confirmation vote so that
there can actually be an investigation
it seemed as though Wow Jeff Flake
standing up here doing the right thing
Republican senator Lisa Murkowski saying
she supports the delay for this
investigation
senators Jeff Flake and Chris Coons who
called for the investigation saying in
an interview last night that if any
lying is uncovered by Brett Kavanaugh in
this investigation that that's it that's
it for his nomination and that this
matters and that it's really important
that this is done that's all great
unfortunately the investigation
and may always have have meant have been
meant to be a total sham controlled by
the White House the FBI has a week to do
this so-called investigation they're not
allowed to investigate the claims of one
of the accusers Julie sweat Nick Trump
is claiming that the FBI can do
absolutely whatever it wants he tweeted
the other day NBC news incorrectly
reported as usual that I was limiting
the FBI investigation of judge Kavanaugh
and witnesses only to certain people
actually I want them to interview
whoever they deem appropriate at their
discretion please correct your reporting
except White House officials are
confirming that certain limits have been
placed here and even when it comes to
investigating the claims of Christine
Blasi Ford and Deborah Ramirez forget
for a second about the third accuser
Julie sweat Nick the White House did
according to multiple reports provide a
list of witnesses that the FBI is
allowed to interview which makes it
completely impossible to actually do a
full investigation and follow the leads
where they take you we also learned that
mark judges girlfriend who has knowledge
of Cavanaugh's friend mark judge
participating in exactly the type of
alcohol and drug riddled gang rape
situations that are at issue here
she tried going to the FBI and she was
completely stonewalled so what we have
here still is a situation that is meant
to do what in the end it's meant to push
Cavanaugh through it is meant to push
Cavanaugh through and at this point I
wouldn't even put it past Republicans to
have sort of tacitly gone along with
Geoff Geoff flakes request because they
knew that it was going to be staged as
part of the plan from day one the FBI
will come back and more than likely
since the scope of the investigation is
limited they'll say well based on what
we were able to look into here's what
the witnesses said period and Senators
will say all right we did the hearings
we heard from Christine Blasi Ford we
did an investigation let's vote and he
becomes the next Supreme Court justice I
don't hope that happens but I do still
think it's the most likely scenario I
suppose you could chalk this up as a
tiny win for Democrats getting that one
weekend
especially cuz they don't have any power
and you know they want something much
broader but this is kind of what they
could settle for but you're right I mean
it's probably gonna come back
inconclusive this happened 30-plus years
ago they'll ask some questions but
ultimately I think he'll be pushed
through the one alternative would be
that even if the specific credibility of
any particular claim can't be
adjudicated that they come back and say
the guy did lie during the hearings and
that would be another story and we'll
talk about that in a moment but to talk
about Kavanagh this is a man who's
fundamentally at the base level unfit to
be on the Supreme Court regardless of
the sexual assault right and then you
remember oh wait he's been accused of
sexual assault by at least three women
that we know about specifically so far
so this is a sham it in dangers the
future of the United States as we know
it and aside from the allegations and
the unhinge rants Cavanagh many times
about small things throughout the
hearings lied Bernie wants a perjury in
VEX investigation and that's exactly
what I want to talk about next let's
focus in now on lies while under oath by
Brett Kavanaugh we already talked about
how he straight-up didn't answer many
questions during that hearing where we
heard from Brett Kavanaugh and from his
first of many accusers Christine Blasi
Ford we already talked about the fact
that many times
senators started picking apart his
claims that he never blacked out from
drinking to the point where he might not
remember what he did on some nights we
already talked about how his sort of
baseline unhinged nature makes him
fundamentally unfit to be on the Supreme
Court but now I want to focus in on lies
that he told remember senators Jeff
Flake and Chris Coons who called for
this investigation last night said if
any lying is uncovered that's likely the
end of this nomination for Brett
Kavanaugh so this matters okay it's
really important to understand that
Cavanaugh is lying about lots of little
things and that should disqualify him
from being on the court even if it's
each individual lies small or relatively
unimportant it's still against the law
to lie under oath and it still makes him
a liar people who know Cavanaugh are
flooding out saying he lied he
many times during the hearing every few
hours there's a new article with people
who know him saying this was a lie that
was a lie
Cavanaugh lied so much actually that
it's hard to even know where to start
but let's first start with his claim
about getting into Yale part of Brett
Cavanaugh's unhinged ranting on Thursday
included him saying that he got into
Yale on the basis of his hard work and
that he had no connections to Yale
whatsoever he his exact words that day
were a quote senator you were asking
about College I got into Yale Law School
that's the number one law school in the
country
I had no connections there I got there
by busting my tail
in college this is a lie Brett Kavanaugh
was a legacy admission to Yale meaning
he had prior family members who went to
Yale his grandfather
Everett Edward Cavanaugh went to Yale to
little lie it's one of many but why is
he lying all the time and why do we need
to excuse those lies he claimed that a
Devil's Triangle is a drinking game it's
not other than references added from a
congressional IP address to Wikipedia
after his hearing he knows that it's a
sex act involving two men and a woman
and it's yet another lie he claimed that
the term bouff related to flatulence
which it doesn't Cavanaugh knows that it
relates to anal sexual practices he
implied when talking about his drinking
that he was of legal age by saying you
know in 1982
I drank beer 18-year olds could drink so
the seniors could drink legally that's
right the seniors who were 18 could
drink legally he wasn't 18 at the time
it's a small lie but it's yet another
lie and then there's kind of like the
bigger narrative lies okay
Cavanaugh's broader story was I just
didn't drink enough to forget stuff I
didn't drink enough to have foggy
memories despite the fact that Senators
Booker and Blumenthal and others made a
Klobuchar and others made some pretty
significant progress in showing that
that wasn't true but before and since
Cavanaugh's testimony a bunch of his
classmates have come forward to say he
was frequently stumbling around drunk he
had no rational
control over his actions nor a clear
recollection of them he was asked during
the hearing whether he watched Christine
Blasi Ford's testimony he said no but I
plan to watch it later it was widely
reported in multiple media outlets that
he was watching the testimony the fact
that Cavanaugh lied so much about so
many little things is actually
indicative of his they can't touch me
attitude which he shares with who he
shares that attitude with Donald Trump
when you were this willing to perjure
yourself you should not be on the
Supreme Court you really shouldn't have
any government job private companies are
free to decide Pat do they care about
the fact that this guy lies all the time
or not he really shouldn't have any
government job and as I said before it's
not likely that there's going to be a
perjury charge proven here it's unlikely
we're even going to get a perjury charge
but at least one senator is getting
tough on the crime of perjury by Supreme
Court nominees and that's Bernie Sanders
who has now actually written a letter to
Chuck Grassley who's been running this
entire circus of a confirmation hearing
saying the FBI should investigate not
only the claims of the accusers but also
whether the guy lied whether he perjured
himself and in his letter Bernie Sanders
said in order for this FBI investigation
regarding judge Bret Cavanaugh's
nomination to be complete it is
imperative the bureau must not only look
into the accusations made by dr. Ford
Deborah Ramirez and Julie sweat neck
which they're not doing by the way it
should also examine the veracity of his
testimony before the Judiciary Committee
obviously Bernie also points out that
they should investigate the claims of
all three women they're not doing that
either Julie sweat Nick attempting to
get in touch with no luck I would make
the case actually that perjury
allegations or may be more damaging than
the sexual assault allegations not that
lying about what booth means is worse
than raping a woman that's not what I
mean
but what I mean is no matter what the
FBI comes up with with regards to sexual
assault it's still gonna be a
preponderance of evidence thing and more
than half of Republicans as I'll tell
you later don't even think sex assault
should disqualify you from the Supreme
Court in that sense if you perjure
yourself it's much more cut-and-dry
Republicans will still say I don't care
put
on the court but I actually think that
you you can make the case that being a
sloppy drunk in college isn't
necessarily disqualifying from being on
the Supreme Court lying about it
constantly as an adult under oath
however should disqualify you from being
on the court it's all just so hard to
prove though like when he claims that
Boo f---ing related to flatulence not
anal sex or The Devil's Triangle that's
a drinking game not a sex act I mean in
his circles he could claim that that's
what those terms meant you can't just
cite urban dictionary and say there's a
discrepancy here or you know I mean his
classmates will come out and say that
this guy drank a lot in college right he
was intoxicated every Friday and
Saturday night him it's it's
unbelievable to think that he could
remember some of that stuff well hey if
he says that he didn't black out how are
you gonna prove otherwise
and when it comes to perjury it does
involve whether he was deliberately
saying something that wasn't true or
whether he genuinely is just mistaken so
it's an uphill battle but I agree with
Bernie that the lying has got to be
investigated here send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show we've
got a great program for you today the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is John Kelly we are mostly supported by
members and patrons and John has signed
up at WWJ pakman.com and I really
appreciate that I also want to say
thanks to Jordan Hicks who has been a
supporter since 2013 today sustaining
member of the day John and Jordan thank
you join them at WWJ impact mancom get
the bonus show the commercial free audio
and video streams of the show all that
great stuff and the pleasure and
satisfaction of knowing that you're
supporting independent media ok there's
one more angle to the Brett Kavanaugh
Fiasco that I do want to talk about
today despite the fact that Brett
Kavanaugh was clearly lying during the
hearing with his accuser Christine Blasi
Ford last week despite the reality that
we all should understand that this guy's
completely and totally unfit to be on
the Supreme Court it's still very
possible that he will be the next
Supreme Court justice but there might be
I'm like really looking for some kind of
silver lining or upside here there might
be an upside to that happening before
the midterm elections in just five weeks
which is that there's a new poll which
claims that voters will punish their
senators if they vote to confirm
Cavanaugh there was a poll conducted by
change research which says that 51% of
voters are less likely to reelect their
senators to vote to reelect their
Senators if they vote in favor of
confirming Brett Kavanaugh 50% also said
that they would view the institution of
the Supreme Court as less credible if
Brett Cavanaugh is confirmed
these aren't overwhelming numbers it's
like a very slight majority within the
margin of error but the point is that
when control of the Senate hangs in the
balance for Republicans when there are
many races that are going to be really
close there's a risk if you're a senator
who votes to confirm Brett Kavanaugh if
you're up for re-election that the
voters who are going to vote for or
against you are not going to be pleased
and in fact this is a time when the
campaign finance system we have
should be used to our advantage and what
I mean by that is I think the campaign
finance system we have as a disaster you
know that if you pay attention to this
show but right now this is the system we
have money should be raised immediately
millions by a super PAC that will do a
blitz of ads targeting senators who are
up for re-election in November and who
vote to confirm Brett Kavanaugh I want
to change the system we have
but right now use that system to do
something good
gather as much money as you can build up
the war chest this week so that as soon
as the vote happens the TV ads can start
immediately your Senator Lindsey Graham
voted to confirm accused serial sex
assault or Brett Kavanaugh to the court
vote him out this November because we
know Republicans don't care about the
sexual assault and I have a poll that
will tell you that in a second but if
there is going to be something that
could kill Cavanaugh's nomination it's
not going to be the moral outrage over
what Cavanaugh did or didn't do we know
they don't care about that it's going to
be Republican senators that want to keep
their seats
if the polling starts to show that their
seats are in jeopardy if they vote to
confirm Brett Kavanaugh you actually
might see some Republicans say well hold
on a second here hold on a second here
Jeff Flake is retiring right but all of
a sudden you have other Republicans who
are running for re-election if they
think a confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh
will make them lose their seat they will
oppose him because you know what in the
end Trump's gonna get a different person
up there
Trump's going to get someone in there
that is the way that you might be able
to prevent Cavanaugh from getting on the
court I mean 50 percent or so saying
that they would be less likely to
support their senator for re-election
that doesn't sound all that promising
but you have to remember that's
nationwide right so if you take a look
at the states that have a Republican
senator but they're more left-leaning
like Maine with Susan Collins or Alaska
with Lisa Murkowski I think that's where
you have a chance because it's not 50
percent there it's probably
significantly higher that's exactly
right
and this is the way if if there is a way
forward to successfully block this
nomination it's going to be the people
that Pat name's Susan Collins Murkowski
there are others that we could talk
about make them afraid
of losing their seats and make them
actually believe they will be punished
if they vote to confirm this guy now
let's reset for a second I just told you
that a very slim majority of Americans
say they will punish their senators by
voting against them if they vote to
confirm Brett Kavanaugh why is it that
it's such a small majority because
Republicans overwhelmingly don't see
sexual assault as a disqualifier for
being on the highest court in the land
this is I wish that it was anything
other than disgusting but it's
disgusting
in the American political two-party
dichotomy there is one party that has
made a living selling the idea of being
the moral party the ones that are for
Family Values the ones that are for all
that is good according to God and that
is the Republican Party now we know it's
a scam it's always been a scam right
recently the election of Trump even by
evangelical Christians despite his
affairs and his multiple wives and more
than a dozen sexual assault accusations
that's proof that it was always a farce
from the right that they were about
morality and the family and all that
stuff there are lots of examples I think
that our audience has a pretty good
sense of that already in the middle of
this debate around Donald Trump supreme
court picked Brett Kavanaugh there's a
new poll that's really important in
understanding how this is all going to
go down the future of Brett Kavanaugh is
not going to be determined by whether he
sexually assaulted someone or didn't
sexually assault someone his future is
going to be determined as I've told you
by a combination of whether number one
Republican senators think that they will
suffer politically from voting for his
confirmation number two whether he
provably lied about drinking or blacking
out or sort of parallel issues to the
sexual assault and number three by how
Donald Trump is feeling on any random
day when he decides either Cavanaugh's
my guy or he decides I'm sick of this
and he calls Kavanaugh and he says step
aside I'm gonna pick somebody else
missing from that you might have noticed
is that this is not going to be decided
by whether Brett Kavanaugh sexually
assaulted someone and as more proof even
more
proof of the total morale vacuity of
this republican party we have a poll
from over the weekend done by The
Economist and YouGov which asked if it
were proven that Brett Kavanaugh
sexually assaulted a woman when they
were both high school students 36 years
ago do you think that that does or does
not disqualify Cavanaugh from being a
Supreme Court justice 71% of Democrats
said if Cavanaugh did the sexual assault
that disqualifies him from being on the
Supreme Court period another 16 weren't
sure in other words only 13% of
Democrats said sex assault wouldn't
disqualify Cavanaugh still too high but
only 13% among Republicans think you
know where I'm going
55% of Republicans said that proven
definitive sexual assault would not
disqualify Brett Kavanaugh from serving
on the Supreme Court and another 18% are
sure aren't sure that means that 73% of
Republicans didn't say that sexual
assault proven sexual assault by Brett
Kavanaugh would be a disqualifier for
being on the Supreme Court this is a
serious issue for the United States the
right will hear me say this they're
going to email me they will troll me on
Twitter they'll say David the numbers
are simply partisan if it were an Obama
nominee or a Democrat running for
Congress accused of sexual assault
Democrats would be defending them and
they would also be saying the sexual
assault wouldn't be disqualifying I've
seen no evidence of that Pat when it was
Democrat Anthony Weiner who was a critic
used multiple times of all sorts of
stuff what Democrats were coming to
Anthony Weiner's defense I can't think
of anybody certainly nobody prominent
when senator Al Franken was accused of
quite frankly nothing close to this
write it what he did was inappropriate
inappropriate joke involving a woman a
flak jacket and and and a vest and you
know you remember the story you still
didn't have people on the Left defending
him you did hear people say well you
know this is not what Bill Cosby did you
can't say that al franken's like Harvey
Weinstein that's all true you didn't
have the left excusing sexual assault in
this manner particularly when the
allegations are far more serious so
putting Cavanaugh on the court at this
point wouldn't happen
despite Republicans belief that sexual
assault should keep you off the court
they just don't think even if he
sexually assaulted someone he should be
kept off the port off the court and this
shows us how the Republican Party has
become like a magnet for morally
challenged unethical people we talk
about similarities between Republicans
and Democrats and differences the GOP
has become the place where this type of
thinking and belief is absolutely
attracted and to pursue their goals this
isn't really necessary this doesn't have
to be the hill that they're gonna die on
Trump could just replace Cavanaugh pick
any one of a number of justices who are
just as bad on the policies right yep we
also don't want but don't have sexual
assaults in their history and the reason
that the fact that they won't do that is
pretty telling there have been many
studies pointing out the way that
conservative brains differ from liberal
brains when it comes to fear centers the
processing of certain types of
information we need a study that
explains the Selective suspension of
morality and ethical beliefs and it's
got to be centered around the political
party known as Republicans consider the
Selective morality or maybe it's the
manipulation of morality that gets a
Republican to a place where they can
think we don't care about Cavanaugh's
personal sexual assault as long as he'll
make abortions illegal as a Supreme
Court justice it is a truly backwards
world or country that we are living in
and we're not just fighting the lies by
Cavanagh we're actually fighting a party
that mostly doesn't care whether he's a
sexual assault or or not it's way
tougher to fight that it is much more
difficult to fight against that and
certainly part of it is their attitudes
towards this whole thing to the boys
will be boys attitude the locker room
talk attitude the idea that if a woman
was sexually assaulted it's somehow her
fault based on what she was wearing or
going to that party alone that night I
mean it's it's not just about political
consequences
it's how these people think many of them
have shifted from there's no chance
Cavanaugh did any of this stuff to
listen even if it's as described boys
will be boys and it's sort of okay that
he tried to rape someone right I mean it
that's how far the goal posts have been
moved or that Kristen Christine Blasi
Ford is telling the truth but she's miss
identifying yes person who did it as if
you were raped you would just kind of
forget who the person was there was this
moment where Diane Feinstein said how
did you know that it was Brett Kavanaugh
who did this to you and she said the
same way I know I'm talking to you right
now right and you have to ignore that if
you want to follow that idea that they
could both be telling the truth it's
just that Christine Blasi Ford is
talking about someone who is not Brett
Kavanaugh I want to hear from you about
this make sure you're following the show
on instagram at david pakman show we
will post some poll results related to
this there also want to hear from you on
my personal Instagram page
david dot pack follow both of us twitch
break back after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to be joined today by Ross
Clark who's a columnist and a leader
writer on The Spectator also author of
the war against cash the plot to empty
your wallet and own your financial
future and why you must fight it Ross
I'm very interested in this topic I was
recently in Europe in Denmark I don't
believe that I touched local currency at
any point because the country has
essentially gone completely cashless if
not by default sort of de facto in a
sense let's first talk about why there
has been this move in many parts of the
world and then maybe we'll get into some
of the concerns about it what's
attractive about going cashless um from
our point of view or from the financial
organization's point of view or
government's point of view yeah I mean
certainly not your it sounds like you're
not in favor of it so what would be
attractive to those who find it
attractive I guess um well I people it's
easy in some ways just to go around
tapping a card against a little card
reader and not fumble around with um
cash that that may be an advantage but
um I'm not against um electronic means
of payment I mean when we're making that
choice to use it that that's absolutely
fine by me and obviously if we're you
know buying stuff over a distance
something we need to do it in some
electronic form if I've order a book
from Amazon or something I can't sort of
get the cash to them immediately so I
don't have a problem with electronic
forms of payment that the problem is
when it becomes compulsory when cash and
businesses governments and so on try to
squeeze cash out of use doing away
effectively with the competition that is
offered by using cash I'm going to turn
your question around a little I mean
what is attractor Burke using cash well
it's free when you and I can do business
with cash we don't have to go through a
middleman we don't have to pay anybody
we don't have a bit of our transaction
creamed off by the payments industry and
you've only got to ask yourself what's
in it for the payments industry well an
awful lot um at the moment the the
payments industry is extracting 1
trillion pounds a year from us um by
2020 they reckoned that will climb to 2
trillion pounds that is the value of the
cashless society to the payments
industry and that that's just from fees
the the other area which the payments
industry helps to cash in on the
cashless society vets and move it or not
um is through the collection and the
sale of data on our spending habits you
know what when we go down to a local
store and buy a coffee or something with
cash there's no record of that we could
be anybody buying it but you use your
contactless card your credit card or all
some kind of electronic means of payment
and that is registered it creates a
little bit of data a little creates a
little bit of a pattern of your spending
habits and that is extremely valuable
data to marketing firms because then
they know what we're buying they know
the sort of stuff we'd like to buy they
can target us with advertising special
offers and and all the rest and you know
a large part of this move towards the
cashless society is being driven by that
industry by the data intelligence
industry if you like so let's adapt to
that momentarily I mean to go back to
the first part it's important for people
to understand that even if to the
end-user you say well I either pay 10
dollars in cash or 10 dollars with a
credit card
it's sort of the exact same cost to me
it's important to understand that for
every transaction the business is paying
a fee to the merchant bank payment
processing gateway at some point if we
move completely off of cash those fees
are going to be priced into what you pay
for products in other words the business
is going to make a decision as to
whether they want to take a loss as a
result of accepting digital payments or
whether they just want to pass on those
payments to the consumer I think most
will do the latter and then at the macro
level you individually might put ten
bucks on your credit card and then pay
it off within 30 days and not pay any
interest but in total we know that
people carry balances and not only does
the merchants collect a transaction fee
then they collect interest on the
balances that people carry so for them
it's a it's a huge boon at the beginning
and at the tail end of the transaction
yes and the direct fees as well I mean
not if in Britain you buy something with
your debit card or credit card and
perhaps in America as well there is no
direct fee but in many countries there
is in Australia for example you use a
contactless card you will pay a direct
fee an extra 1/2 percent or something
like that and if you use your debit card
abroad I mean I was in Russia last week
I paid a hotel bill for two hundred
pound was around two hundred pound
um the card company charged me nearly
ten pound to process that payment I mean
that that's that's quite a lot of money
went in where ever ever I go abroad now
III you know take the cash with me or
I'll take a large amount of cash out of
a ATM machine as soon as I arrive in the
country well that gets me to the next
thing because there is a risk to
carrying the cash right and and so I
have moved significantly in it in the
direction of planning ahead when I
travel overseas are outside of the
United States and figuring out do I
really need to have cash with me because
one of the advantages that seems very
real to me which is worth paying
to me 1 2 or 3% is that if I don't have
cash on me the cash can't be lost or
stolen and if I have a credit card if
the credit card is stolen I just stop
payments on the credit card there is a
program which prevents me from being
ultimately responsible for payments that
somebody else makes would it be
reasonable to say that that's worth a
few percentage points um if you realize
you've lost your card and you can cancel
you're in a position where you can
cancel it instantly that's ok that will
save you but um if you lose a
contactless card the contactless cards
we now use in Britain um anybody can
make a purchase of up to 30 pounds with
those cards without giving any ID
without putting in a pin without
producing any kind of identification
um you're potentially gonna lose a lot
more if you lose your contactless card
than if you lose an amount of cash or or
if it's stolen
I suppose it's possible but don't I mean
again I'm kind of just thinking of
thinking it through with you even if you
don't in my experience even if there are
fraud even if I haven't lost my card but
somehow somebody has you know digitally
forged a copy of my card and made
purchases even after the fact
I've never altom utley been responsible
for a payment they didn't make oh well
bank some payment companies will often
try and wriggle out of reimbursing
people in those situations and it's been
I mean I looked at I looked up some
figures the eye I found a figure and I
did this for the United States and I
also did it for Britain the number of
people percentage of people who had lost
cash in the previous year with the
percentage of people who had fallen
victim to some kind of card fraud either
having their card cloned
having it stolen having it used without
permission and these people actually
ultimately lost money and there was no
comparison though the the percentage of
people who are losing money through card
fraud is significantly higher than those
who are losing money through
cash being stolen so did the idea that
yes theoretically an electronic payment
a card payment is traceable but it
doesn't actually mean that police or any
other kind of authority is actually
tracing that those payments and I don't
know how it works in America but if you
have you've lost money on a card fraud
in Britain earring up the police they
don't show any interest at all yeah I
agree with that it's I've just never
heard of anybody needing to do that
because they were able to handle it
through through the credit card company
but I think that there's sort of like a
parallel issue here which I am much much
more concerned than some of the other
issues which we've mentioned so far
which is for me moving to cashless
moving to credit payments and and
technology based payments it seems like
it will have a the effect of
significantly increasing inequality and
what what I mean by that is that once
again we will be creating a system
whereby those who are more rural than
urban or suburban those who may not have
the financial means or credit to obtain
some of these mechanisms will be sort of
further pushed out of certain elements
of the economy and and I think that that
really is a concern I don't know where
you weigh in on that well that's
absolutely true and I mean we're moving
now to I'm not just sort of system of
card payments there's a lot of payments
industry trying to push us all towards
some paying with our smartphones well
you know if you've got a system where we
have to pay with our smart phones you
will first see you will you need a smart
phone you need it to be fully charged up
you need some kind of internet reception
and as you say there are a lot of rural
areas which don't have good internet
coverage its disadvantaged in that the
people making the purchases and also the
businesses I mean how how do you opera
how would you operate a business in a
remote area if you could only accept
payments by um electronic means and as
we've got smart phone ownership there's
a lot of people find it very very
difficult
to use a smartphone um you look at other
business you know the ownership of
smartphones almost Universal among young
people but in Britain um there's only
18% of over 65s actually owned a
smartphone um makes it because people
find it very difficult to use they're
very fiddly um if you've got arthritis
or suffer from other some other
disability which makes it difficult to
use um I have a daughter who has
learning disability she can handle cash
she can understand cash but to operate a
smartphone and to deal with all those
fiddly sort of apps programs whatever
you want to call them that's extremely
difficult for she's she's not going to
be able to do that and um you exactly
sort of person who will be disempowered
um so through a cashless society and
governments payments industry seem quite
happy to push this drive to cashless
payments without actually considering
people like that at all thinking out
loud and this is speculative of course
are we better off trying to figure out
how to solve some of the problems you
just pointed out if we accept that there
is a certain inevitability here because
I'm sort of reminded of you know when
there was this argument made that we
really should push back against the
development of motor vehicles because
the horse buggy drivers are going to go
out of business and thinking now that
that might have actually prevented the
development of the modern automobile it
seems completely inconceivable is there
some element of inevitability here no I
think motor cars are very interesting
parallel really because you go back to
the sort of 1960s and we had sort of
predictions that you know all households
would have a motor car by 1985 therefore
we should design all our cities around
the motor car and never mind pedestrians
cyclists they won't exist in the future
because everybody will be going by owned
by car um well certainly in Britain car
ownership has never exceeded more than a
70% of households and that's actually
falling now you know it's quite clicking
cars motorcars aren't gonna go away
they're far too useful for that but you
know there's no need to try to a little
bit was it a very silly idea to try to
eliminate pedestrians eliminate cyclists
from our cities because um you know give
people the choice of how to move around
and um you know we now know further the
environmentally point at the point of
view is extremely good thing that people
walk and cycle around and I think you
know we're in that position now with
cash and electronic payments we're at
that position as we were with cars in
the 1960s when companies and businesses
governments are saying oh we won't need
cash in future because everybody will
pay to have everything electronically
you know I that should not be allowed to
happen we you know in 3040 years time I
predict we will still be using cash in
for some forms of payment because it is
very convenient it's some cheap it's
free to use and for yeah and because
it's um gives the the poor the people
with disabilities it gives them a means
of taking part in the economy which
would be very hard to achieve through
purely electronic means all right I
don't pretend to know what we will be
doing in 40 years but I I'm curious to
know that's for sure we've been speaking
with Ross Clark columnist and also
writer on The Spectator the book is war
against cash the plot to empty your
wallet and own your financial future and
why you must fight it I really
appreciate you sharing your point of
easy too
thinking the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
Donald Trump had another one of these
very strange rallies over the weekend
this one was in West Virginia and at
this rally he said that he fell in love
with North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
that that's the headline and it seems
like a joke it seems like it would be a
parody but it's real and I'm gonna play
the audio and video for you if you are
watching you'll notice an
extraordinarily sweaty and disheveled
Donald Trump and almost out of breath as
well explaining that he and Kim jong-un
have fallen in love those are his words
not mine because of the beautiful
letters I was almost able to do it
because of the beautiful letters that
Kim wrote to him and I want to do more
of an introduction to set up the clip
but there's really nothing else to say
let's take a look at it and yes I agree
the rhetoric was unbelievably harsh at
the beginning but we have a very good
relationship we were going to war with
North Korea that was what was going to
happen we are doing great that was a big
big problem and you know the interesting
when I did it and I was really being
tough and so was he and we'll go back
and forth and then we fell in love okay
oh really he wrote me beautiful letters
and they're great letters we fell in
love but you know what now they'll make
just like Donald Trump said they fell in
love
how horrible how horrible is that so
unpresidential and I always tell you
it's so easy to be presidential but
instead of having 10,000 people outside
trying to get into this packed arena
we'd have about 200 people standing
right there it's not that it's
unpresidential that Trump says he fell
in love with Kim jong-un it's that it's
extraordinarily disturbing particularly
when Trump seems unable to get along
with our allies like Germany France
Canada England and yet again it's
literally love letters with one of the
worst dictators in the world and it's
not about wishing that we continue to
have a bad relationship with other
countries it's it's never been about
that why is Trump so impressed with and
taken by literally enamored with people
like Kim jong-un and
Dajuan and Putin and Duterte it's about
Trump going to the UN General Assembly
last week and praising Kim jong-un who
remember husband hasn't done a thing
towards fulfilling his promises from
that bogus Singapore summit and he says
nothing about actual Russian election
interference for example or anything
about praising our actual allies and
then putting aside the specifics of this
very strange comment about Kim jong-un
why is our president always cozying up
to dictators Bannen Steve Bannon
previously said that Trump gravitates
towards strong personalities which to me
sounds like those daddy issues that we
know Trump has had based on his
up-and-down relationship with his late
father it is amazing how we thought like
a year ago that Trump had said the
strangest most bizarre things he would
say that's nothing compared to stuff
like this like I fell in love we are in
love he is in love almost knocked over
my mug there we are we are now in love
and when I saw the headline Trump and
Kim jong-un fell in love I thought it's
got to be a misquote or an onion article
or something like that it's literally
what he said that they fall in love yeah
it's a long-distance relationship yes
what I'd call it it's the kind of thing
that lends itself to so many jokes I
mean like the Trump Kim jong-un
meeting and everything that they had
since then all lends itself to jokes but
kim jong hoon is such a terrible
dictator and perpetrator of so many
human rights abuses this I feel like
maybe we shouldn't be joking about it
it's a lot more serious than this it is
serious and I would also say if you work
for the onion or SNL how do you take
this and satirize it this it's a self
parody to the enth degree it's totally
unimaginable okay I've got to talk about
something that I think some people
aren't going to like you know that on
this show there are no sacred cows right
this is a left-wing progressive show so
a lot of the criticisms are of
right-wing ideas and of right-wing
people but there's no shorts there's no
short fall there's no shortage of
misguided left-wing ideas and left-wing
people and I call them out I don't
believe in tribalism that says even if
there are people on the Left who are
toxic or have bad ideas you can't
criticize them because they're part of
the same movement the same tribe the
same left-wing so last week we got a
live call as you know Pat we don't
screen live calls for topics
people can ask anything they want and a
caller said David what do you think
about Jimmy Dore who's now going to
battle against Sam cedar or Bernie AOC
Andrew Gilliam Gilliam I don't even know
how he says his last name and I gave my
opinion I gave my opinion as I always do
which was to say in this case that I
think Jimmy Dore has become totally
toxic I think he's a useful idiot and a
tool of really bad movements and I got a
ton of angry emails and dislikes and
even a handful of people who had paid
subscriptions to the show who canceled
them this is really a concern it's a
concern for me but it's a concern for
the left here's an example email okay
this is from former member Jacqueline
who said David it's very disappointing
that you have opted to do an on-air
attack to do on air attacks on Jimmy
Dore quote completely toxic useful idiot
and dum-dum left were the choice words
by extension you are referring to his
audience as well which happens to
overlap with your audience sadly I was
foolish enough to pay the annual fee for
my Pakman membership which was valid
till next dot I still cancelled anyway
you can consider this hatred mail if you
so choose but that's not what it is by
having segments attacking other
progressives who aren't lockstep with
your views you are the one being toxic
this is one of a handful of people who
wrote me stuff like this and canceled
memberships so first of all just
consider the irony that they say I'm
being toxic by attacking a progressive
who's not in lockstep with my views by
canceling their memberships
because I think door is toxic they are
attacking me financially for not being
in lockstep with their views it's sort
of the same thing this is really
important okay don't miss the irony of
that but more importantly the left can't
be like this okay there are bad ideas on
the left and right there are bad faith
actors on the left and right there are
way more on the right and we mostly
focus on the ones on the right but
consider the opposite when I get a call
that says David what do you think about
the direction Jimmy Dore has gone in my
alternative instead of giving you my
honest opinion is to lie and say he's
doing great work would the audience want
me to lie and just say something like
that because of tribalism or so
I don't anger certain people in the
audience I can't imagine that that's
what the audience wants and if the idea
is that I need to turn the show not into
what I genuinely think but instead into
what the leftist group think has
determined is better for quote the
movement that is a tribalistic disaster
so assuming you don't want me to lie to
you
basically people who canceled because I
gave my honest opinion about Jimmy are
saying they're cancelling because I have
the wrong opinion and I think that
that's really dangerous because as I've
said before no two people are going to
agree on everything ever right and if
independent media is going to survive
and thrive which I believe it needs to
do okay it can't depend on the financial
support that exists only up until
there's a disagreement on one issue
right of course people can choose to
support me or not support me for any
reason right or any other show for that
matter but this is why the right is
succeeding in so many ways they have
made a commitment where they say let's
support people who are basically on our
side they might be anti-gay but if
there's a pro-gay rights Republican
who's mostly on their side and helps
their movement they support that person
they are anti-abortion but if there's a
pro-choice conservative that's generally
furthering I don't know there's small
government views or they're low tax
views or whatever they support that
person if this is how the left is going
to sit decide who we support we're going
to fail okay and by the way if we apply
the no support if they say one wrong
thing idea what about all the people who
were supporting jimmy dore despite the
fact that he did at one point push seth
rich conspiracy theories if you don't
buy that stuff and i think most people
in my audience do not wouldn't that be
disqualifying of your support for jimmy
right so the main point is let's not
allow ourselves to be ripped apart in
this way and we can't do this type of
tribalism this type of tribalism is
going to destroy the movement from the
inside out if you really think the
problem is only
progressives making honest critiques of
other progressives when they feel
they're warranted and making critiques
of the right when those are warranted
that is not actually the problem and we
really need to think hard about what it
is that we're saying when you say I'm
pulling my support because I disagree
with you about this issue or that issue
or think that it should be off-limits to
criticize other progressive media I want
to hear from you about this we did hear
by the way at our voicemail number two
one nine to david p we heard from the
kansas troll who you might remember
about a year ago pat he called in and
totally face-planted during a live call
and since then he basically goes on
hiatus for like three to six months at a
time and then leaves a completely
outrageous voicemail he's done exactly
that
he claims here that women use their
vaginas against men god bless Brett
Kavanaugh and all sorts of other crazy
stuff take a listen to this yeah uh I
wanted to say your take on the Cavanaugh
situation by the way God bless Brett
Kavanaugh in the Cavanaugh family your
take is complete crap we all know women
in professional worlds but basically
anywhere else have no problems flooding
around but they call it sexual assault
and rape when they don't get you know
whatever promotion or whatever guy they
wanted and women use their vaginas as
ploys against men and the majority of
women actually do orgasm during rape so
by virtue of women are liars and this
woman's testimony should never have been
admissible in the courts was it yeah
Dave you are a complete pathetic [ __ ]
you may see it anemic queer that's
always on the YouTube screen you're a
total man Johnny no you little prick
Backman there you go this is a deeply
deeply angry person this is somebody who
is in need of very very serious
intervention but the the the reason I
bring it to you is because he gets to
vote just like everybody else right and
this is this is actually what we're up
against this is what we're fighting
against and when people don't have a
real argument they do get upset and
unleash attacks like this personal
attacks it's there's no wonder why he'll
leave for a few months and then try to
bill
that this confident and then kind of guy
yeah really sad but that's why we have
to vote because he gets to vote just
like you and I we've got a great bonus
show for you today I'm out of time to
tell you what's on it but you can get
access as a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show or as a member at WWE
at medCom
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you